what I'd like to do in this video is
give you an overview of the Khan Academy
SAT resources the official SAT resources
that we've been able to construct
alongside with our partners at the
College Board so right when you go to
the resource it'll ask you a few
questions the first one is are you
trying to practice for the SAT or the
PSAT the tests are obviously related but
then this will help the the system just
know what you're actually trying to
target and in the first version of this
it's primarily about SAT but that's
still going to help you for the PSAT
that it says next - question - I got to
answer four questions here the SAT is
changing in March 2016 which SAT do you
want to practice for the current SAT the
new SAT or I'm not sure so let's say I
want to do the new SAT and then we'd
like to be able to let you know about
upcoming SAT events in your area such as
Saturday in-person practice tests and
local study groups and this is actually
something we're very excited about and
of course we're never going to sell your
personal information it's just to notify
you when interesting things are going on
so I could put in my zip code right over
there and then question for our system
we'll create a personalized plan that
focuses you on practicing the skills you
need to improve the most and it's going
to start me on for short diagnostic
quizzes that should each take about 10
minutes each and says well where do I
want to focus on first and let's just
say I want to focus more on math and
let's let's do this thing so here we are
we said we wanted to focus on math first
and you see there's two tabs there's
reading and writing and then there is
math it defaulted me to math because
that's what I said I want to focus on
first and then we see here that there
are that there are four quizzes that I
could take each of them should take me
roughly 10 minutes they're going to have
10 questions on them and the goal of
these and I encourage you to kind of
take the time out to do these as well as
you can don't just kind of guess the
answers because this will inform the
system
where you are at different skills and
the goal of doing four quizzes with ten
questions each is by doing these 40
questions you're essentially covering
all of the major dimensions that you
might see in on the math SAT and so the
system will say okay what are you
stronger at and what are you weaker at
and then we'll be able to give you
personalized prac
let's take one of these quizzes just to
see what it looks like and so it says
the quiz is not timed we'll assign you a
starting strength for every skill on the
quiz it says calculators are not allowed
and once again this is all for your
benefit to get a sense of what you know
and what you don't know and like on the
new SAT there's no penalty for guessing
so let's start let's start this quiz
alright so I'm going to kind of pseudo
try to answer some of these and then a
few of them I might just guess just for
the sake of time Salma is filling her
water jugs with spring water at the
supermarket the above equation gives the
empty space and her jugs V in u.s.
gallons after T minutes at a constant
fill rate how many minutes will it take
to fill the jugs so let's think about it
when the jugs are filled there's not
going to be any empty space so this is
going to be equal to zero so what time
we'll make V equals zero you have no
empty space left well time would be six
point four so after six point four
minutes so let me type that in six point
four let's let's finish this diet
diagnostic and what do we have all right
well we get a report and on this report
we see that I was able to get nine out
of the ten questions right for the ones
that I was able to get right I'm going
to start at skill level three and what
is skill level three you ask well we've
we've broadly been able to chunk the
types of items that you've seen on the
SAT into three skill levels skill level
two skill level three and skill level
four and you might say well what is
skill level one then well skill level 1
would be the prerequisite knowledge that
you might not actually see on the SAT
but if you're having trouble with skill
level two we have resources that will
allow you to build those foundations in
that prerequisite work but you saw the
things that I got right linear
inequality word problems linear function
word problems operations with
polynomials the system is now going to
say hey Sal I'm going to start you at a
higher skill level at skill level three
which is not the most challenging but
the second two most challenging level
because you've got everything you got
these right here and you can see that in
this little dial right over here where
three out of the four are filled in but
I got one wrong and as far as the system
knows well hey maybe we'll start you two
slightly less challenging level for
interpreting non-linear expressions
because of that one there but if i want
to say well hey you know III feel like I
got this one right well let me see why I
got it wrong I can review my answer so I
click review answers well I got that one
right and this was the wrong this was
the one that we got wrong so it not only
does it show me what I selected but it
tells me why it is wrong we would use
vertex form to reveal the maximum
minimum this model has a minimum so and
it tells us what is the right answer is
the right answer was this right over
here was C and we could review the rest
of our questions or we could just exit
the diagnostic and now once we exit the
diagnostic we can take more of the
quizzes and once again I encourage you
to take the time out to properly do
these quizzes have some scratch paper in
hand so you can give your best shot Adam
so you can give the best information to
the system so it can give you the best
recommendations afterwards after you've
finished these four quizzes then the
system is ready to start recommending
things to you and so this is what it
will look like after you finished your
four quizzes and you see these these
four I guess you'd call them activities
are things that the system things that
you could work on so data collection and
conclusions and you notice right right
here it has and this is just this one
bolded up if we click on this one and
that one gets bolded up on top if we
click on that when that one gets bolded
up on top and it says this is this is
the system's current best guess of the
skill level that I'm at that I'm at two
out of four now I'm going to practice if
I click on practice these skills that
I'm actually going to get exercises in
them and if I were to get if I were to
get them right then I'm more likely to
be promoted to start working on more
challenging skills and so the whole idea
here is that I'm always able to work on
the skills and the difficulty level or
the challenge level that is appropriate
to keep me getting better all the time
it doesn't help you if you're working on
stuff that you already know really well
it doesn't help you if you're working on
stuff that you have a lot of trouble
with your best working on the stuff that
you have a decent chance of getting but
you're still struggling with a little
bit that's what's going to improve you
the most now these three are just
standard practice sessions I guess you
could say and
this one over here is a timed mini
session it says calculators okay so you
can get your calculator out for this one
and this one is to kind of give you a
mini kind of practice under a little bit
of time pressure because obviously when
you take the standard of the SAT or
really any standardized test you're
going to be under time pressure and so
this will let you practice under under
those conditions now if you scroll down
if you scroll down you could see that
there's all this stuff down here what is
this well up here this is what the
system thinks that you're best off
working on but it also recognizes hey
you might have in your own mind the
things that you want to work on most and
so that's what you could pick over here
hard of algebra and it gives all the
subtopics their passport to advanced
passport to advanced mathematics gives
all the sub subjects there it gives the
best read on how much you have it what
level you are at each of these and you
can either click right over here and get
practice problems in that exact section
or you could click on the videos to see
example videos in that in that in that
topic and if you click on easier it's
going to give you an easier example if
you click on harder is going to give you
a video of a harder example so that's
what's and you just are going to ideally
just keep working on that a little bit
every day so that you keep getting
better and better do a lot of deliberate
practice and really kind of build your
muscles in the areas where you you might
be less familiar and once again all of
this is stuff that you will have seen in
school and so a lot of this might be
review for you or filling in gaps that
you might have not filled in the first
time that you saw them in school now
that's on the math that's only part of
the SAT we also have a very similar
thing for the reading and writing so
once again you have your diagnostic
quizzes like we mentioned and after that
it'll give you suggested practice and
just to see what it looks like we can
check and go down to see what these
these things look like say on writing
argument you can see that it actually
matches very similar to the form factor
that you would actually see on the SAT
even even so that when you actually take
it in real life you are familiar with
kind of what hey what is this one with a
dark box on mean well you'd be familiar
with it when you take the actual SAT but
you have your you have your pass
your sentence correction right over
there and so that's math that's reading
and writing those are kind of your two
main dashboards for practicing and doing
deliberate practice if you want some
kind of high level things about the SAT
you can go to tips and planning and then
you know and you can click on any of
these videos or read some of these
articles and then if you want real
full-length practice exams you click up
over here and you see these complete
practice exams and these I encourage you
to really take as much time out as
necessary to simulate real test taking
conditions because this is where you're
going to what you'll take these simulate
the test get practice in that and then
that's also going to give information to
the system on what you need to work on
more so you could take these practice
exams just kind of with a standard paper
and pencil but the value of taking it on
this system is after you take it one
it'll be Auto graded but on top of that
that information of what you got wrong
what you got right will be used to give
you better guidance and give you better
practice so anyway there's a lot to
think about just now but hopefully you
find this as valuable as or as fun as
some of us do and good luck with
everything